this is the soldier spending 10 days in
an Israeli Army prison Israeli activists
have gathered in the occupied West Bank
City of Hebron on a fact-finding trip
it became very violent very quickly the
soldiers have been suspended it's not
clear what other punishment the soldier
who threw the punches now faces but the
soldier who verbally abused one of the
activists has been jailed for 10 days
the activist asked if filming the
incident was against the law the soldier
responded I decide what the law is and
you are acting against the law he also
invokes the name of the man likely to be
Israel's new security minister Ultra
nationalist etmar Ben gevir saying Ben
gevir will make order here you've all
lost it all you do here is finished as
he walks away you can see the skull
patch on his uniform which says one shot
one kill No Remorse I decide Edmar Ben
Giver visited the family of the man
jailed he demanded the Army rethink the
punishment saying the sentence was not
right and inappropriate Edmar bengafir
was already a controversial choice for
the new role of national security
minister he has a conviction for
incitement and links to a group
described by both the U.S and the
Israelis as a terrorist organization now
he's being accused of dragging the
Israeli Army into a political role and
criticizing the leaders of an
organization you'll have to work with
very closely
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera West Jerusalem